13h08 cela fait plus de 4 heures que les
réserves d'oxygène du Titan se
sous-marin qui emmenait 5 personnes à
côté du Titanic devraient selon toute
vraisemblance être épuisé on va parler
de ce sujet on va suivre ce qui se passe
effectivement en direct sous-marin
disparu y a-t-il encore un espoir et
j'en parle avec Vincent Bordenave
journaliste sciences au Figaro bonjour
Vincent merci d'être avec nous pour nous
expliquer un peu où on en est
aujourd'hui et on va peut-être aussi se
rappeler de
la jeunesse pour commencer cela fait
maintenant 96 heures que ce sous-marin a
plongé au niveau du Titanic ça fait plus
de 96 heures c'est d'ailleurs que que
ces problématiques parce que le
sous-marin le sous-marin il a quitté son
son va son vaisseau amiral lotion prince
dimanche
en tout début de matinée heure locale ce
qui fait aux alentours de 13 heures ici
et donc on est à plus de 4 jours et les
réserves de ce sous-marin en termes
d'oxygène et de survie parce qu'il y a
pas que l'oxygène il y a aussi le fait
de recracher du CO2 quand on respire et
tous ces éléments là fait que on avait
une capacité de survie de tour de 96
heures et donc on a dépassé ça depuis
maintenant plus de 6 heures et ce qui
fait que les chances de retrouver les
les passagers de sosuma encore en vie
sont faibles pour avoir nul on peut le
dire on peut le dire désormais
c'est alors déjà c'est 86 heures c'était
un compte à rebours mais il y a pas mal
de variables qui entendent il faut pas
imaginer une horloge qui défile avec des
minutes qui s'égrènent et à un moment
donné on est en vie et le moment tout
s'arrête
malheureusement les choses enfin les
choses ne se passent pas comme ça
malheureusement ou pas d'ailleurs
c'est quelque chose de de beaucoup plus
lent et dilué c'est à dire que la
respiration des individus va impacter ce
ce cette durée on a à bord
un spécialiste de la plongée en
sous-marin qui s'appelle paul-hen
argelet qui qui est le grand spécialiste
au monde du Titanic mais qui en plus
c'est un expert de de ces plonger à haut
risque et de tous les tous les experts
mondiaux c'est-à-dire pas seulement ceux
que le Figaro a pu rejoindre mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est aussi la lecture
de la presse à anglo-saxon là dessus
expliqué que s'il y avait une chance
survivre pour pour
ces passagers c'était la présence à bord
de de
ce Français parce que il y a une façon
de se comporter qui va permettre de
gagner quelques minutes peut-être
quelques heures par des positions par un
contrôle une maîtrise de soi l'absence
de panique tous ces éléments là qui vont
permettre d'économiser de l'oxygène qui
vont permettre de rejeter un peu moins
de CO2 mais là ça fait 6 heures que le
délai des 96 heures est passé donc les
gains
qui auraient pu avoir par ces techniques
là sur une position de se mettre en
position de foetus ce genre de choses
sont maintenant sur mon en dépassé c'est
pour ça que quand bien même on
retrouvait le sous-marin les chances de
retrouver des individus dedans sont en
vie sont nuls et je répète parce que le
fait de retrouver c'est pas suffisant
parce qu'après il faut quand même le
sortir de l'eau il prend un enfant aussi
donc il faut le remonter c'est ça va
demander dans tous les cas beaucoup de
temps pour arriver à remonter ces
sous-marin qui se rappelle et quand même
à 4000 mètres bon c'est pas où il est
c'est ça le problème c'est que on sait
pas où il y a plusieurs possibilités ce
qu'on sait c'est que environ 1h45 après
ça mise à l'eau donc dimanche matin il y
a une perte de contact le contact du
sous-marin avec le bateau le bateau
Mercedes c'est un pinger c'est tout
simplement un pin qui a envoyé qui a
répondu qui répond pardon qui répond
au niveau au niveau de navire c'est
comme ça que je fonctionne la toute
les balises sonores c'est comme ça qu'on
positionne des balises sous dans l'eau
pour calculer les positions en géologie
c'est comme ça qu'on communique avec
avec les équipements sous-marins et ce
Ping a cessé de fonctionner la
profondeur était trop importante pour
qu'il puisse avoir un échange de SMS
parce que c'est aussi l'eau de manière
de communiquer mais on sait pas où il
est on
va partir au moment où on a une heure 45
de de latence entre le départ et l'arrêt
de la communication on peut supposer
qu'on est aux alentours de 3008 donc la
profondeur du Titanic mais comme on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé le le sous-marin
a pu continuer à dériver et si dérive si
ces moteurs sont en panne comme la
communication est en panne on peut on
peut imaginer que c'est une panne
générale de l'habitacle le sous-marin a
pu lentement dérivé remonter à la
surface ce qui prend aussi plusieurs
heures et peut être actuellement quelque
part
à la surface de l'eau mais donc il y a
une immense zone à chercher s'il s'agit
quand même un petit sous-marin qui fait
6 mètres si je me trompe pas de de
longueur donc il a trouvé c'est quand
même
je suis pas du tout en train de vous
dire qu'il est à la surface je dis que
c'est une possibilité l'autre
possibilité c'est qu'il soit retrouvé
bloqué sous les sous l'eau la carcasse
du tyrannique c'est un endroit
extrêmement dangereux
le bateau enfin le les pavs les pas
immobilier la chimie marine fait que il
y a de la roue il y a des bactéries qui
mangent qui mangent les métaux et on
n'est pas l'abri de chute et on n'est
pas à l'abri même pour un pilote aussi
expert que les monsieur narjolais on
n'est pas à l'abri de se retrouver piégé
c'est une hypothèse qui est quand même
et pas à privilégié par les gens qu'on a
pu avoir au téléphone une part parce que
marjolais connait l'endroit comme
personne et c'est compliqué d'imaginer
se laisser piéger mais aussi parce que
s'ils sous-marin est piégé ce serait
quand même hautement improbable que en
plus le système de communication se
remettre à tomber en panne c'est pour ça
que la panne est privilégiée mais ça
reste une possibilité donc là dans ce
cas le sous-marin ce serait toujours
serait à 3800 mètres de en profondeur et
les habitants les habitants les
occupants encore encore encore en vie il
y a encore quelques heures en tout cas
la dernière possibilité c'est celle d'un
souci au niveau de la structure il
suffit d'un petit trou on est à 3000 m
3008 de profondeur et la pression est
énorme et un petit trouf est totalement
implosé le le
sous-marin et dans ce cas là
la mort des
occupants très bien ce produit il y a il
y a quatre jours maintenant donc on a
perdu le quand on a perdu le contact
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est tout
à fait possible et on a aucun élément
pour aller vers une de ces pistes
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui effectivement on
verra ce qui ce qui se passera dans les
dix jours à venir parce que les
recherches continuent bien évidemment on
s'attend pas à ce que ce soit les
recherches s'arrêtent ça ça va continuer
pour aussi trouver finalement des
réponses oui oui et puis parce que
le miracle est toujours envisageable
souhaitable et si quelque chose qui qui
va pousser à mon avis les équipes de
recherche et puis aussi parce que donc
ça c'est le premier élément on cherche
toujours au-delà parce que dans des
séismes on a trouvé des personnes qu'on
pensait morte longtemps après longtemps
après le tremblement de terre longtemps
après après un long séjour sous les sous
les décombres mais aussi et ça c'est des
raisons peut-être un peu plus
rationnelles parce que c'est important
de savoir ce qui s'est passé retrouver
le sous-marin permettra de savoir ce qui
s'est passé et c'est compliqué et puis
pour le travail de deuil aussi c'est
important de retrouver des cornes donc
c'est compliqué d'arrêter maintenant il
y a énormément de il y a un dispositif
de ce cours qui est très important avec
une dizaine de navires de plusieurs
nationalités il y a un navire français
de de l'Ifremer donc l'Institut de la
recherche en mer
française qui qui arrivait sur place
dans la nuit dernière qui a qui a
déployé un Rohff donc c'est à dire
[Musique]
des débris si jamais le sous-marin est
bloqué qui pourrait attacher un cap
parce qu'il y a aussi un navire
britannique et équipé d'un d'une
structure qui permet de déployer un
câble de plusieurs plusieurs kilomètres
même de d'une dizaine de kilomètres qui
permettrait de remonter le sous-marin la
surface
maintenant si jamais si jamais le
retrouver sur place il y avait déjà un
autre offre mais qui était capable de
plonger seulement à 3000 mètres qui
permettait de scanner un peu et qui a
pas qu'il y a pas qu'il y a pas trouvé
de traces du chemin effectivement alors
je vais vous lire quelques quelques
commentaires beaucoup de gens qui qui
sont tristes bien tristes grosses
pensées pour les pour les victimes c'est
4B TV qui nous dit ça
un compte utilisateur qui nous dit quand
on voit la conception de sous-marin
est-ce que c'était une bonne idée de de
monter dedans alors c'est c'est une
question tout à fait légitime il faut
déjà considérer bon il y a trois
individus qui dans ce sous-marin ont
payé très cher pour pour voir le Titanic
et ensuite il y a le le président
directeur de l'entreprise
Océane qui organise ses excursions et le
dernier à bord donc le français était
embauché par ochengen pour mener à bien
cette mission c'est sous-marin avait
déjà plongé à plusieurs reprises on
estime que
il a amené à une soixantaine 70
personnes à peu près déjà à 3800 mètres
de fonds
mais
quand on a appris que ce soit disparu on
a commencé à passer quelques coups de
fil et rapidement une chose est venue
quand même c'est que tous les experts
qu'on a pu avoir au téléphone on dit y
compris les amis de de de narjolais nous
ont dit avant son départ on lui avait
dit mais tu es sûr de vouloir aller dans
sous-marin tu as confiance et il y avait
des doutes parce que dans sa structure
correspond il était extrêmement innovant
en terme de
matériaux composites et il y a un hublot
qui est extrêmement qui est très grand
qui fait 60 cm pour comparer le hublot
du Nautile qui est le sous-marin de
l'Ifremer qui qui va assimiler de fond
il faut savoir qu'il y a qu'une dizaine
de sous-marin dans le monde qui vont à
ces profondeur et il fallait aussi
trouver un sous-marin qui qui reviendrai
je viendrai après là-dessus sur cette
question parce que c'est vrai que c'est
important et je reviens juste sur sur
hublot le hublot du nautique fait
seulement 12 cm tu l'as fait 60 cm c'est
une différence qui est énorme et on a
appris là parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
documents qui sont sortis c'est un des
jours que il est quand même designé pour
un sous-main qui descend à 1300 mètres
de fond donc il y a plein de plein de
points d'interrogation plein d'éléments
de sécurité mais
[Musique]
je trouve que cette comparaison est
bonne un ami de narjolais m'expliquer il
faut il faut l'imaginer dans la tête
d'un pilote d'esthétique il était à fond
inquiet mais à la fois hyper excité
d'utiliser une nouvelle technologie et
de de tester ce cet engin de voir
comment est-ce qu'il peut être maniable
et d'essayer quelque chose de nouveau il
savait qu'il y avait un risque mais
c'est un explorateur et c'est quelque
chose qui qui
pour lui était extrêmement important et
qui l'amenait à tenter des expériences
que le commun des mortels n'aurait pas
on n'aurait pas on n'aurait pas envisagé
et donc aujourd'hui il y a
malheureusement de fortes chances que
qu'il y ait laissé sa vie mais par le
passé il a pu faire des choix tout aussi
dangereux qui sont qui sont avérés juste
parce qu'il est revenu et il a permis de
découvrir et c'est un peu aussi pour ça
peut-être qu'on est passionné par cette
histoire que on suit ça avec beaucoup
d'attention parce que il y a ce côté là
quand même exploration moi ça me fait
beaucoup penser à ce que je peux lire
dans sur le top des héros les premiers
les premiers Américains qui ont permis
la conquête spatiale ils montaient dans
des dans des engins qui étaient
extrêmement dangereux dans lequel il y
avait vraiment très peu de chances de
survivre et pourtant s'ils ont passé le
mur de son pourtant ils ont réussi à
dans l'espace quoi donc il y a ce
côté-là le spatial le sous-marne et
l'océan profond c'est deux univers
extrêmement hostiles ou peu d'individus
ont pu aller il faut des explorateurs il
faut des des gens qui ont pas les mêmes
rapports à la vie à la mort que que
commun est mortels pour y aller quoi
alors je vois beaucoup de commentaires
dont un je remercie d'ailleurs
je vais retrouver tout de suite Mike et
nabir qui nous dit ils ont retrouvé des
débris près du tyannique effectivement
ça vient de tomber ce sont les
garde-côtes américains qui annonça des
débits retrouvés dans l'Atlantique près
de l'épave du Titanic on attend plus
d'informations vous pouvez retrouver
bien évidemment notre notre direct je
vais vous le montrer qui est ici sur le
site du Figaro
là voilà vous pouvez retrouver notre
direction le site du Figaro avec toutes
les dernières les dernières informations
à retrouver bien sûr sur le site du
Figaro comme on le disait beaucoup qui
nous disent voilà un préparation
le
discours du du patron de l'entreprise et
qu'il a refroidi
le niveau de la préparation de de cette
expédition est hallucinante donc voilà
c'est un peu ce qu'on disait j'aimerais
qu'on parle du du robot qui a été qui a
été envoyé qui a été envoyé ce robot il
était aux Açores avant le robot de
l'immer il a été dépêché sur place
on parlait des débris aussi parce que
c'est quand même une information
extrêmement importante mais le robot
donc il est sur il était sur un navire
français la teinte qui est dans une
mission aux Açores et
comme on l'a dit quand le sous-marin est
parti disparu c'est un compte à rebours
qui qui commence et donc on peut pas
faire venir un sous-marin comme le
nautique qui était à La Seyne-sur-Mer en
en France ne serait-ce que parce que le
temps de trajet est très long mais aussi
parce que un sous-marin c'est quelque
chose qui s'organise il faut plusieurs
heures pour le mettre sur un bateau et
plusieurs heures pour le faire descendre
et nous on a on a quatre jours pour pour
réussir à non seulement trouver
sous-marin le sortir de l'eau et
éventuellement trouver des survivants
donc on fait avec ce qu'on peut et on
fait avec ce qui est disponible dans la
zone et donc le le la talent qui était
avec Victor 6000 a pu arriver sur zone
et on a fait le plus vite possible mais
parce que les ingénieurs qui sont
capables de piloter ce ce rêve n'était
pas avec n'était pas sur la talent sans
doute parce que leur mission était
terminée ils étaient revenus en France
on a dû les faire venir on a dû une fois
sur place prendre plusieurs heures pour
faire descendre pour préparer le Rove et
lui permettre d'arriver d'arriver
d'arriver à plonger et de de commencer
ses recherches alors je je j'aimerais
juste sur les débris
c'était l'hypothèse qui a été
privilégiée par tous les gens qu'on
pouvait avoir au téléphone alors on a eu
une lueur d'espoir hier quand on a
entendu des bruits mais aujourd'hui
il y a eu la confirmation que c'est
bruit n'était pas lié au sous-main et ce
qui était quelque chose de probable
parce que une carcasse ça fait du bruit
qui a du métal et que
la circulation du son en eau profond
n'est pas du tout la même que la surface
et la température joue et les indices
nous laissait entendre que il était
quand même fort probable que c'est Brice
soit pas soit pas ceux du sous-marin
il y avait seulement la régularité qui
qui était assez trompeuse et donc
l'hypothèse la plus crédible je l'ai dit
parce que s'il avait été pris au piège
on aurait continué à avoir les Pings et
dans l'autre cas on aurait commencé à le
voir à la surface c'était donc une
implosion du
sous-marin lié à un défaut et maintenant
qu'on a retrouvé des briques peut-être
qu'on va pouvoir
en savoir un peu plus sur qui a pu se
passer est-ce que c'est ce fameux hublot
vraiment tout le monde nous disait il y
a un problème avec ce hublot 60 cm je
vous disais à Pôle Henry mais tu peux
pas remonter dans un sous-marin avec un
hublot de 60 cm tu te rends pas compte
il y avait eu plusieurs plongés
auparavant donc c'est quelque chose qui
avait assuré mais
c'est pas parce que le fait qu'il y a eu
plusieurs plongée c'est un élément qui
est bien évidemment rassurant le Nautil
à jamais rencontré aucun incident après
des dizaines d'années après une dizaine
d'années d'exploitation et je sais plus
combien de plongée en eau profondes mais
pour avoir joint certains experts sur la
question il y a quand même une fatigue
des engins sous-marins à force des
plongée c'est quelque chose qui est
régulièrement surveillé qui est
prévisible
mais
en temps normal il y a une structure
métallique en un seul d'une seule
matière ce qui fait que on arrive très
bien à l'anticiper sur ce sous-marin il
y avait des questions d'alliage il y
avait la question de la jointure avec ce
cette immense houblon prévue pour pour
seulement 1300 mètres et il y a surtout
un vrai point d'interrogation sur les
contrôles et ça c'est ce qu'il y a ce
qui est ce qui est sorti c'est que non
seulement il y avait des doutes que qui
avait balayé d'un revers de main au sein
gate en disant on va pas faire
homologuer certifié notre notre engin
parce que les certifications sont sont
has been c'est mal parlé comme ça mais
c'est c'est comme ça qu'il écrive une
correspondent pas à l'avancée
technologique représente pour pour que
représente ce sous-marin et donc il est
passé pas alors que il devrait les avoir
il s'est avéré en fait que
la personne qui est un sensable de la
sécurité a été démunis de ses fonctions
parce qu'elle avait mis trop de doute il
y a quelques années donc les les les
voyages les plongés récentes avaient
peut-être rassuré mais cette fatigue
liée à au peut-être un défaut structurel
j'en sais rien et peut-être responsable
aujourd'hui de la situation actuelle et
ça ça on le saura dans les dans les
heures dans les dans les jours qui
viennent oui alors il y a des
conférences de presse prévu normalement
tous les jours à 19h donc on suivra là
c'est ce qui ce qu'ils disent en ce
moment
sur le sur le communiqué je vais essayer
de vous le retrouver il est plus haut
sur cette page voilà
des débris retrouvés dans l'Atlantique
près de l'épave du Titanic il va y avoir
[Musique]
sorte de ce qui est habituellement prévu
est-ce que ça peut être un navire qui
qui a coulé et dont l'épave se retrouve
à ce niveau là ça paraît très peu
probable parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on aurait anticipé qu'on aurait pu
calculer et qu'on les garde-côtes
auraient aurait
enfin aurait pris en compte dans dans
leur annonce donc si on trouve des
débris il y a vraiment
énormément de chance que ce soit ce
chemin et surtout ça ça confirme le
scénario le plus crédible qui est de
peut-être celui qu'on a pas voulu voir
parce que quand on est dans la période
de recherche il faut avoir de l'espoir
pour trouver également donc on se
concentre sur les scénarios positifs
donc ce que je disais un sous-marin
bloqué et un sous-marin qui remonte à la
surface en plus il y a eu cette histoire
de bruit qui a alimenté cet espoir et
c'est normal on peut pas en vouloir aux
équipes de secours de faire ça et puis
même aux gens que dans ces métiers de de
porter là-dessus hier j'avais par
exemple un des de dolifremer qui me
disait qu'il avait bon espoir mais
parce que on envoie on envoie un Rohff
parce que on arrive avec un bateau qu'on
y met les moyens et on y va pas si on
n'a pas l'espoir de trouver quelque
chose quoi mais c'est quand même le
scénario qui était le malheureusement le
plus le plus crédible et le plus le plus
probable d'un point de vue scientifique
parce que l'absence de communication
parce que l'absence de trace à la
surface alors que le le signal avait été
perdu 1h30 donc
en dérivant on aurait dû voir le
sous-marin arriver alors on a des on a
des commentaires sur la sur la manette
sur le sur le sur comment cette
sous-marin pouvait se déplacer je vois
pas comment il y a une balle et qui je
vois pas comment un truc qui était
dirigé avec une manette high-tech on
pouvait payer 250000 euros pour aller il
y a plusieurs degrés de réponse à ça la
première réponse c'est de dire que là il
a explosé mais il y a eu des voyages qui
sont allés au bout donc le système de de
comment on parle
s'il y a un problème c'est vraiment sur
sa structure externe et sur sa
résistance à la pression et qui plus est
si on trouve des débris c'est c'est ça
qui font interroger ensuite
il y a peu d'interlocuteurs en fait qui
savent comment se sous-marin fonctionne
réellement c'est toute la difficulté de
de cette de ce de cette situation c'est
que comme il y a pas eu de certification
il y a peu de communication on n'est pas
face aux Nautile ou aux autres
sous-marins qui vont à 10000 que tout le
monde connaît parce que il y a une
certification qu'il y a un cahier des
charges que tout le monde que tout le
monde peut consulter et se dire à
celui-là il y a telle particularité etc
là les meilleurs spécialistes au monde
des sous-mains ont entendu parler de ce
marin connais cette entreprise ont eu
des doutes mais non pas eu accès à un
au-delà de de des éléments de com et on
peut le lire et c'est pas seulement les
experts français parce que on le voit
aussi sur la les experts anglo-saxons
qu'on a pu joindre ou dans la presse
anglo-saxonne on voit il regarde les
vidéos comme nous ils disent ah mais là
il y a il y a une sorte de de de de de
faux de faux murs et donc on peut
supposer que le poste de contrôle est
caché derrière ce cylindre
il y a peu de communication qui a été
faites là-dessus quoi effectivement
alors je vois beaucoup de beaucoup de
commentaires beaucoup voilà beaucoup de
gens parlent justement de cette
préparation on peut rappeler aussi sur
les sur les gens qui étaient qui étaient
présents on sait maintenant enfin ces
gens qui étaient présents il y avait des
il y avait des spécialistes de la
question un spécialiste que j'ai tout à
l'heure pendant une argeler qui est
vraiment le
qui est déjà le meilleur au monde sur le
Titanic et qui est un des meilleurs au
monde sur la navigation dans dans ce
contexte là
c'est un ancien de la Marine qui a passé
25 ans
dans la marine
on dépose de contrôle de Souma il a été
responsable de la flotte de sous-marin
de l'Ifremer il est passionné du Titanic
et il plonge régulièrement
vraiment c'était en plus c'était
c'est cet individu ce personnage était
le motif des sports sur lequel on
pouvait se raccrocher il est trop il est
suffisamment bon pour pour éliminer
l'idée d'une erreur de pilotage parce
que il sait ce qui fait il connaît
suffisamment le Titanic pour se dire
qu'il va pas se laisser piéger et puis
surtout
il a disparu trop tôt pour qu'il soit
arrivé il faut qu'il soit arrivé au fond
oui oui on est vraiment on est vraiment
là il arrive à la hauteur mais 1h45 la
perte de contrôle oui il faut deux
heures à peu près pour arriver au fond
donc c'était aussi c'était quelque chose
qui était qui était qui était pris en
compte mais c'est un aventurier c'est un
explorateur et peut-être que
je retiens quand même c'est la première
chose qu'on m'a dit et on savait pas
encore s'il était à bord on savait pas
encore ce qui si on allait retrouver ou
pas mais tous les gens que j'ai eu qui
sont des proches énergelés m'ont dit je
l'ai eu avant de partir sur cette
mission je lui ai dit tu es sûr de toi
il a dit non mais je veux quand même y
aller parce que je suis suffisent attiré
par la beauté de la mission et puis il y
a il y a quelque chose autre qui qui
le muet et qui le lui permettait de
d'aller là-bas c'est t'exprime cet
esprit d'aventure qui est propre aux
grands explorateurs
on en parlait il y a un parallèle à
faire avec l'espace par exemple de de au
début de la crise spatiale sur un peu la
même chose finalement les pilotes
d'essai tout ça qui fait ça il se voyait
comme ça alors je vois qui vous êtes
encore très beaucoup vous êtes pas vous
êtes vous êtes très nombreux à nous
suivre on vous le rappelle la dernière
formation qui est tombée à 17h58 sur le
site du Figaro des débris retrouvés dans
l'Atlantique près de l'épave du Titanic
on le disait au début de ce live on le
redis aujourd'hui on le redit maintenant
en tout cas les chances de retrouver de
les retrouver sont quasi quasi nuls oui
elles sont nulles on dit quasi nulles
parce que tant qu'on a pas de cadavre il
y a pas de il y a pas de mort et parce
que on aussi peut-être que nous-mêmes on
se on a une certaine pudeur par rapport
à ça et pour pas respecter pour pour les
familles bien entendu mes d'un point
opérationnel d'un point de vue
factuel
les chansons nuls et il y a ce motif
d'espoir ce miracle qu'on espère tous
mais là les débris sont sont pour moi le
enfin déjà au-delà des 90 heures parce
que je vous avais dit il faut un temps
pour pour remonter le sous-marin pour
pour
organiser la sortie donc on n'a pas
parlé parce que c'est plus d'actualité
mais remonter quelque chose comme ça ça
prend plusieurs jours oui ça prend
plusieurs heures en tout cas et
plusieurs on y va très vite il faut
déployer un câble il se trouve que sur
place on avait on avait l'équiment en
terme de cap qui était qui était
possible mais c'est quelque chose
extrêmement lourd donc déjà à partir du
moment on avait on approché des 96
heures on savait que ce serait très
difficile à partir du moment on les a
dépassés quand même on retrouve le
sous-marin on le retrouvera
occuper seulement par des par des par
des morts et là maintenant qu'on a des
débris on on
confirme ce que ce que ce qu'on savait
déjà quoi c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
écrivait dans le journal
prévu demain matin alors qu'on n'avait
pas encore cette information sur les
débris c'est que les l'espoir l'espoir
est terminé c'est pas terminé merci
beaucoup de d'avoir été avec nous je
vous rappelle vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les informations sur le site du
Figaro avec cette information la
dernière des débris retrouver dans
l'Atlantique près de l'épreuve du
Titanic une communication devrait suivre
d'ici quelques temps par les garde-côtes
ils feront une annonce merci une
nouvelle fois Vincent Merci à VOUS du
Figaro d'avoir été nombreux à nous
suivre et moi je vous dis bonne soirée
sur fireless